quand j'ai commencé j'avais les mains
bien mises après j'ai grandi après
c'était plus ça j'avais plus ce
mouvement là elle ne savait pas encore
lire que tenir la batte était naturel à
14 ans mlissa ma collectionne les titres
de meilleure lanceuse et de MVP meilleur
joueuse du championnat sélectionné en
équipe de France de softball et de
baseball depuis un an capitaine de son
équipe au cougar la jeunee n'a pas
atteint ce niveau par hasard
Missa va essayer de d'apprendre le geste
le plus consciencieusement possible le
répéter à l'infini pour pouvoir
s'améliorer maintenant ce n'est plus sur
une globalité de jeu qu'elle a à prendre
c'est sur des points de détail et c'est
pour ça qu'il lui faut des des coachs
qui soient du niveau national pour
pouvoir construire son son jeu depuis
quelques mois les plus grandes
fédérations étrangères lui font les yeux
doux en octobre dernier elle est invitée
à découvrir le baseball féminin japonais
dans quelques jours la lanceuse des
coupgard va s'envoler pour C Cu pour
participer à un stage avec la sélection
nationale canadienne en vue des
championnats du monde 2014 mais elle
reste les pieds sur terre et ne compte
pas abandonner son club formateur pour
autant j'aimerais bien pouvoir jouer
jusqu'à 18 ans en France et après
pouvoir partir à l'étranger dans une
université et pouvoir faire quelque
chose dans le basball pour l'instant je
me débrouille j'arrive à bien faire les
deux mais il y a des moments où ça
devient compliqué il faut faut parfis
louper des
entraînements sin c'est quand même
l'école qui reste prioritaire ah oui oui
de toute façon sans écle on peut rien
faire malheureusement pour le club
cinquantinois la réglementation ne
permet pas aux filles de jouer avec les
garçons après l'âge de 15 ans seul le
softball leur est ouvert mais Mélissa a
déjà fait son choix c'est vraiment ma
passion je veux je veux pouvoir
continuer à jouer toute ma
vie